hello everyone and welcome to the
European Team Championship we have a
clash on board one between Austria and
Norway representing Austria we have
Valentin dragnev and representing Norway
is the number one rated player in the
world Magnus Carlson you can see that
there's some 250 rating points
difference uh but that doesn't matter as
uh well if you if you have to win it's
always very hard if your opponent is
playing well so I made a video the other
day about how you should never resign
how you should always keep fighting and
this is well this just uh gets it to to
a completely different level but in that
spirit so let's check it out uh
Valentine has the white pieces and he
opens with E4 Magnus goes for his
Sicilian Defense we have Pawn to C5
Knight F3 Knight to C6 and now Bishop to
B5 he goes for the medino rosimo attack
Pawn to E6 and now castles we have
Knight G to E7 and Rook to E1 and here
uh A6 is the most common move but Magnus
goes for Knight to D4 it's a bit of a
trickier line but still very much played
Knight captures C captures and pawn to
C3 now challenging the pawn here uh Pawn
to A6 we have Bishop back to F1 and now
Knight to C6 and here uh we have Pawn to
B4 most likely an unpleasant surprise
for Magnus Carlson because Magnus
already played this exact position with
black uh he played it against Maxim
bashra and Maxim continued with B4 and
defeated Magnus back in 2021 one so okay
Bishop to A7 they continue uh in the
same fashion as the game mentioned Pawn
to A4 we have castles and now Knight to
A3 uh D captures on C3 and now D
captures on C3 we have Bishop to F6 and
now Maxim played Pawn to B5 right away B
Valentin plays Bishop to B2 which is
actually the strongest move recommended
by the engine so he sort of improves on
Maxim's game uh and now there are a
couple of games where D5 was played but
here we have Pawn to D6 by Magnus and it
is now as of move 13 that we have a
completely new game so okay Queen to B3
continuing development putting um more
more uh fir power behind that B5 push we
have Queen to C7 and now Rook a to D1
the D6 Pawn is weak uh and of course you
want to attack it at some point we have
Rook to d8 Knight to C4 now putting more
pressure on D6 and now Pawn to
B6 uh otherwise you might have some uh
chances of playing A5 maybe put a knight
on B six but uh mostly the Knight is
coming to E3 and then you will control
D5 you'll control F5 you will have F4 F5
maybe uh and so on the usual stuff
against the Sicilian B6 we have Knight
to E3 and Bishop to B7 now we have
Knight to G4 putting pressure on
magnus's Bishop and Bishop to G5 we have
Pawn to C4 now grabbing more space here
and gaining more control over the D5
square and pawn to H5 kicking away the
Knight but uh Valentine does not Retreat
he goes goes Queen to C3 threatening
check sorry threatening Checkmate we
have Pawn to F6 defending and now Pawn
to H4 offering to trade Bish Knight for
Bishop here Bishop captures on H4 we
have Queen to H3 and now H captures on
G4 we have Queen captures on H4 and now
Knight captures on B4 uh and Rook to E3
so of course he wants to go Rook to G3
capture on G4 and uh well threaten the
the G7 Pawn or maybe even just capture
here go back and then put everything on
the H file and then try to threaten the
black king via the H file so Pawn to E5
a very good move by Magnus this sort of
renders the dark Square Bishop kind of
useless for the moment but also frees up
this diagonal for the light Square
Bishop uh to join the action we have
Queen captures on G4 and the immediate
Bishop to C8 attacking the queen queen
H4 and now uh we have Bishop to
E6 uh interestingly Bishop to E6 loses
the game for for Magnus but it's such a
complicated position uh that it was not
exploited in the game here you have to
play Pawn to G5 first and Magnus wanted
to play Bishop E6 and G5 uh but move
order really matters here because if you
play G5 right away then look at this
Pawn to Rook to G3 and now if Queen to
G7 defending you have everything
defended for example Queen to H5 you
will play Bishop to E6 and you played
okay Bishop to E6 and pawn to G5 the
difference in the defense with Bishop to
E6 first is that now Rook to G3 cannot
be countered with Pawn to G5 now if you
play Pawn to G5 there's this nasty
Bishop to C1 move and The Rook moved
from E3 so Bishop captures and G5 is
actually a terrible threat if you play
something like Rook D7 you want to help
out with the defense still just captures
F captures and now Queen to H6 first the
bishop on E6 is undefended so you will
lose use that to uh lift your queen up
the board and now it doesn't matter
let's say Bishop captures on C4 you will
capture here and now finally after Rook
captures on G5 check King F7 Rook G7
check King to E8 and now of course Queen
to h8 check you will have to block with
the queen and then you'll just Checkmate
the black king so that's the difference
between uh Bishop B6 followed by G5 and
G5 followed by Bishop to E6 so Magnus
has to figure out a different defense he
plays Rook to f8 and now we have Bishop
to C1 again waiting for that G5 push
from Magnus we have Rook to A7 and now
Bishop to E2 and now Magnus plays Queen
to d8 again allowing uh uh Valentin here
to uh take advantage of this uh position
uh but again it's very very complicated
he played Rook to G6 which is very nice
uh but F4 seals the deal right away I
will show it just because it's a lot of
fun for example F4 if you capture on F4
then Bishop captures will put put too
much strain in Black's position with the
the D6 Pawn hanging in the balance and
also if you don't play that if you play
F5 which is the the strongest defense
recommended by the engine then Rook G5
and after Knight to C6 you will play
Bishop to H5 with the idea of Bishop to
G6 followed by Queen to H7 Checkmate so
you have to stop this bishop to F7 and
now Rook to D3 and now the other Rook
joins the attack for example Bishop
captures You'll Play Queen captures and
after Queen E8 offering a queen trade
you will play Queen to H6 and again the
D6 Pawn is very weak the The Rook is
coming into the attack via the G3 H3
squares that's how you win this but uh
easier said than done Rook to G6 was
played right away which is still
perfectly fine uh Rook to D7 by Magnus
and now we have King to H2 interestingly
Bishop to H6 here is the the way to go
point is that after Bishop to H6 yes the
G7 Pawn is covered but uh even after
let's say Rook F to F7 uh Bishop to H5
comes that's the problem and now if you
start running away with the King now
Bishop to G4 is very strong this
undefended bishop on E6 is always the
problem for example Bishop C captures
Bishop captures on G7 check first and
after Rook captures now you go Queen to
h8 with check and after King E7 now you
start capturing Rook captures on G7 King
to E6 and now even Rook to G8 uh putting
pressure on the queen and also the the
problem is that the bishop will get
trapped once the queen moves if you want
to save the queen you have to play
something like Queen to C7 and then F3
also wins the bishop here so the black
king will not survive on on E6 uh but
okay here uh King to H2 was played first
uh with the idea of bringing the Rook
into the game not we have the D3 Square
since Magnus is reluctant on moving the
knight from B4 the D3 square is guarded
so now uh Valentine wants to play Rook
H1 and then uh put the king just back to
G1 and okay Magnus gets sort of a free
move here Rook F to F7 and now Rook to
H1 we have King to f8 Magnus now starts
running away King to G1 and now King to
E7 we have Queen to G3 the idea is of
course put more pressure on that G7 Pawn
Queen to G8 defending we have Bishop to
E3 now going after the undefended B6
pawn and Rook to B7 so uh the weak
points G7 and B7 are and B6 are the ones
that have to be defended at all times
and now Pawn to F4 this is the true uh
move to break through e captures on F4
Bishop captures and now Rook back to D7
uh adding a Defender here as Bishop
captures on B6 was the threat and now
comes Rook to H5 uh here Valentine had
some four minutes on the clock Magnus
had over 20 minutes and two more moves
need to be played in order for time
control to be reached so this is a a big
big moment for Valentin uh Magnus plays
Knight to C6 and now again valentin's
position is winning but he has to find
the correct idea now there are there
were so many possibilities for pause the
video moment in this game as it's it's
really a complicated one uh but I
thought this would be a nice one so feel
free to pause the video and try to find
the only winning idea for uh for
Valentine uh while I give you a couple
of
seconds so uh for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on always
looking for really weird moves and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is Pawn to A5 that's the way to
break through now you're either breaking
through here or if B captures on A5 then
you will play Pawn to C5 that's the the
the really fun part and if D captures
then Rook captures on C5 and now uh
black will have too hard uh too
difficult a time defending both the G7
and the the Knight here on the C6 and
the pawns are are are destroyed here and
you will just be able to get get in the
position so there's really no good way
to uh to handle everything here on the
other hand where are you moving the
Knight that's also a pretty big question
like Knight to d8 will just be met with
Pawn to E5 completely opening up the
position and now there's really no good
move here if you capture then Bishop to
G5 check comes you go back then Rook to
C8 will come and well very quickly you
you will uh collapse and on the other
hand after A5 if Knight captures an A5
sort of keeping the pawn chain intact
now you again play Pawn to E5 looks
impossible but that's how chess Works D
captures and now you sacrifice the
bishop and after F captures Rook
captures on E6 with check and black
resigns you either either go back and
there's well your position is completely
busted or you capture and you get
checkmated here with this beautiful uh I
don't know what this Checkmate is called
but it really should have a name uh so
that's uh what you should do however
Queen to H4 was played sort of
threatening uh Rook to h8 to trap the
black queen and now Magnus should play
Queen to A8 it's sort of the only way to
survive and I'm again I'm going to show
you because it's a classical game and
these variations are extremely difficult
uh but um even if Queen T8 is played uh
Bishop to G5 still is very very annoying
but luckily now you have Knight to D4
and black survives now the bishop is
hanging after the bishop moves you will
play F captur on G5 and okay now you
will capture Rook G captur on G5 and
after Queen back to f8 uh there's no way
for white to actually do anything here
you're going to go for a discovery a
nice Rook to D5 check G5 now and after
Queen captures now King to E8 and after
Rook captures on D4 winning back the
material now you have Rook F1 check and
after the king moves you will play Rook
to G7 and black is back in the game
however after Queen to H4 this is move
39 so still not reaching time control
Magnus played Rook to d8 and now again
white is objectively winning Queen to F2
was played going after the B6 pawn and
now Rook to B8 again Magnus defends the
B G7 is defended B6 is defended those
are the two weak points H and now Pawn
to A5 it was uh it was uh only a matter
of time before he plays it Knight
captures on A5 and now Queen to D4 and
this queen to D4 is sort of the for or
third imprecise move that Valentin
played and this really allows Magnus
back in the game of course he's going
after the D6 Pawn but it's much more
potent to go uh for the D6 Pawn this way
as it still puts pressure on the uh on
the G7 pawn and now if you play Rook to
d8 for example now again E5 completely
blasts through the position D captures
again you sacrifice the bishop and after
F captures you have this Rook captures
on E5 move threatening to capture on E6
and you can play this because Rook
captur on G7 wins the queen so you have
to defend with this rook and then Queen
G5 check King to D7 and now Pawn to C5
before you start collecting material B
captures Rook e captures on E6 uh what
do you play here Rook captures Queen to
D5 check there's no way to defend here
you will move Rook captures here and
then of course the black king will get
checkmated very quickly however after
Queen to D4 this allows Magnus to play
Queen to d8 now that the queen and Rook
are not pressuring the G7 Pawn the queen
can move and now E5 doesn't really do
all that much so Rook to H7 uh and now
Knight back to C6 attacking the queen
queen back to D2 and now Queen to C7 uh
giving back the giving up the the G7
Pawn but at least you are back in the
game Rook G captur on G7 and now Rook to
f8 we have Bishop to H5 going after the
Rook here H but Magnus just goes Knight
to d8 notice that if you go after Rook
captures on G7 it would be uh it would
be terrible because after Rook captures
you have to block either otherwise
you're going to lose the queen so you're
going to play Bishop to F7 and now you
play Bishop captures and after Rook
captures now Bishop captures on D6
that's how you pull through uh captures
and now of course The Rook captures and
F7 check to deflect the king from
defending the queen here and even if you
don't do it uh Rook captures on F6 seals
the deal captures captures white has a
queen black doesn't this is resigned so
after Bishop to H5 Knight to d8 Magnus
sacrifice prices The Exchange to survive
and okay the game continues Bishop
captures on F7 Rook captures and now
Bishop to E3 so this is the position now
Magnus trades Rooks Rook captures Rook
captures and now Knight to F7 uh we have
Queen to B4 putting pressure on the B6
pawn and now Queen captures on C4 we
have Queen captures on B6 and queen
captures on e4 uh Rook to G8 still
trying to go after magnus's King but now
Bishop to D7 we have Bishop to F2 and
queen to D3 now keeping an eye on
everything and asking Valentin do you
have anything else to to try here Rook
to G3 attacks magnus's queen queen to D1
check we have King H2 and queen to H5
with check and now after defending for
like five hours it seems that Magnus
finally gets his repetition of moves but
no after King to G1 now Magnus continues
and he wants to trade queens and play an
end game because even though he's down
the exchange he is up two pawns so of
course Valentin declines this he goes
Queen E3 check uh Knight to E5 and now
Rook to G7 with check we have King to E6
this is the strongest move uh if you go
back then you will run into some
problems after Queen to A7 uh so King to
E6 and now Queen to H3 with check uh
again time trouble lurks um uh you know
it way back in uh it's Mo 59 and um
Valentin has some five minutes on the
clock Magnus some 9 minutes on the clock
we have King to D5 now Queen to H7 with
the idea of uh well putting pressure on
this Knight and then maybe eliminating
the bishop here but Pawn to F5 by Magnus
uh Bishop to G3 and now Knight to G4 it
looks like Magnus blundered a piece here
but if Valentine grabs the bishop then
Queen B1 check is Checkmate not right
away of course you have to block with
the bishop and then Queen captures on E1
his Checkmate as the Knight covers the
F2 and H2 squares so after Knight G4
Queen to G8 check was played Bishop to
E6 and now Queen to A8 with check King
to D4 and now Queen Queen to A7 with
check King to D3 magnus's King really
looking like a like a fine attacker now
getting very close to that white king uh
But Here Comes Rook to B7 attacking the
queen and now H you really don't have a
a good attacking move Rook to B1 will be
played next to avoid any trickery so
Magnus delivers a check and offers the
queen trade Queen captures on C5 was
played and he was in this position on
move 66 that Valentin and Magnus agreed
to a draw as there is nothing more to be
done here of course you could play a few
more moves like d captures and C5 but
after Rook to B6 you will win the A6
pawn and that's pretty much it um Magnus
will be up one Pawn H but down the
exchange this is uh this is objectively
a draw uh so uh fine Escape by Magnus he
was lost for the entire game Valentin
played a brilliant brilliant game but he
missed a couple of crucial continuations
that would allow him to actually take
down an almost 300 higher rated uh
opponent that is the former world
champion Magnus Carlson uh but yeah
still a fine win and this draw wins his
uh country of Austria a win over Norway
as uh on board for uh Austria also
celebrated Victory so a draw on board
one uh goes really a long way here for
their team so yeah big congratulations
to Valentin he almost almost had it but
luckily luckily Magnus escaped luckily
for Magnus of course and he doesn't lose
a lot of rating points as for for a draw
he l is like a maybe a one point
something rating points uh but yeah
again very nicely played by
Valentin really a gruesome uh game
excruciating pain playing this defending
this but yeah like I mentioned in the
beginning of the video uh this was I
mean this is how you defend uh so yeah
always you know persevere and may maybe
it works out for you uh so yeah once
again really hope you guys enjoyed it
and also I'm very interested in hearing
have you watched the UFC today if you
guys follow that what do you think think
about the fights and what do you think
about the two two top Main Events uh
very interested in your thoughts on that
uh so once again hope you enjoyed it I
would like to wish a very happy birthday
to Manar and I would like to thank Kevin
Clark Camilo he Schwarz Randall ingersol
and stepan rovic for your contribution
to my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World H thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day